yeah it's very important in our work we
have been working with women we are
working with children they're working
with girls when we started we encourage
their families to send their children to
school making sure everybody goes to
school girls are not left behind as a
result we can we could achieve the
hundred percent of the children going to
school today we have seven and a half
million borrowers all over the country
in Bangladesh and all their children I'm
school and we give them a scholarship
those were top performers and we deserve
half the scholarship for the girls and
other half is open for both girls in
bars as a result sixty-five to seventy
percent of the scholarships go to girls
because we see the tremendous impact in
the family in the person's life and the
future of the girl and now we have
created helped we have been in the
process of creating health care program
where women and children and adolescent
girls will be the focus because a very
important if you can build up the health
of the women and the children and
adolescent girls that changes the whole
scenario of ill health and malnutrition
and so on so this we want to do it with
you in a way those were the victims of
the neglect of health care the real
victims of the again the mothers and the
children and the adolescent girls we
will be using mothers and their dollars
and girls to become the forefront of
delivering this health care services so
that those who sufferance they are the
deliverers also so it's not there for
professional people coming from outside
and really I'm telling you what to do
they themselves would be since the
sufferer they understand those issues
that they will be doing yet so this is
what we are looking forward to redesign
the entire health care system in
Bangladesh in a same way that we have
done the redesigning of the financial
system to come to the poor people
particularly for women and it will be a
social business so that it covers its
cost like we did in financial services
and that's what we are looking for I
think will be so we'll succeed even the
technology of it technology of
delivering healthcare it's now possible
because amazing technology is waiting so
the doctor doesn't have to
come in physical contact with their
impatience anymore we can make the
contact possible to information
technology like just now I am talking to
you using same technology and doctors
can be doing the same kind of thing
using information technology bringing
all the health services to all the
people in the country thank you very
much